it is great to have Rick Sanchez joining
us today veteran journalist and Emmy
Award winner who is the co-founder CEO
and president of agua media Rick it's so
great to have you on
listen um David I I
am so proud of you as a fellow Latino
everything you do uh your determination
your ability to always fight for the
little guy your consistency uh General
fairness your messaging uh you do a
great job David and and you ought to be
commended and I just got to be telling I
got to tell you with all transparency
I've been a fan for some time I've been
listening to what you do and you do a
really great job so there you go I'm
shocked and flattered but also it
provides like a really good segue into
when we think about the Dynamics of the
American
Spanish-speaking or Latino origin
Community there it's such a diverse
Community many people see me they say
David you look white how is it that
you're South America what's and of
course you and I and many people in our
community we know about the diversity
but politically it's also quite a
diverse group and as as I want to hear
from you the conventional wisdom is
often Cubans and Venezuelans they often
come to the U.S they become Republicans
because they see that as a way to fight
that which they left in their home
countries those from many other South
American countries in Central America
tend to be more democratic leaning is
that the is that still accurate today
I think to a certain extent it is
unfortunately it's overplayed so what
happens is like with the election with
Trump for example Trump did in fact you
know get his uh he gets credit for
winning Florida unfortunately he didn't
win Nevada he didn't win Texas he didn't
win anywhere else in the country 70 of
the people in the United States are not
Venezuelans or argentinians or Cubans
they are for the most part either
Mexican or from other parts of Central
America but that message gets lost David
so still uh the message seems to be that
all the Latinos are moving to the
Republican Camp
um and that's not true uh Latinos
continue to vote basically two-thirds uh
Democrat and one-third Republican and
that's changed a little bit over time
but it seems to me that the message
that's coming certainly from the right
the right is spending millions and
millions of dollars with Americano and
all these other front groups to try and
bring in and Sorrows for example to try
and bring in Latinos
they get credit for trying but
considering the amount of money they're
putting into it and considering how
little competition they're getting from
Democrats to try and keep Latinos there
they actually aren't doing that well I
wouldn't score them highly on that yeah
it's interesting because you often
touted is oh in 2020 Trump increased his
share of the Latino vote by eight
percent but when you start with a small
number even increasing it is not super
impressive but that being said if the
trend continued it actually would be
hugely significant
well sure and they even did well in this
last election if you want to go by uh
decimal points yeah and I think to a
certain extent look I mean let's just
call this what it is how much can
Latinos be told that they're rapists and
criminals by certain segments of the
Republican party like Cruella Deville
running for governor in Arizona and you
know after a while it's uh obviously
going to create a backlash the the
problem and I wish what I would see is
more David Pacman's and more Rick
Sanchez's and I'm not just trying to say
that we're the only ones that got this
thing figured out but I'd like to see
that on the NBCS and the cbs's and the
cnns and other places where they don't
just uh kowtow to Latinos and uh tell
you about how much they like you but
actually understand that we're the fifth
largest GDP in the world if we were a
country that 80 percent of us are
American citizens that uh uh 30 of 40 41
of us uh under the age of 50 English as
our language none of these things are
proliferated so I I don't I think
both the Republican Party beating the
crap out of the Latinos uh and then the
Democratic party unfortunately not going
far enough to really represent or
understand Latinos almost even taking
them for granted to a certain extent
creates this Dynamic that we're in right
now and it's got to change on both sides
obviously one of the stories that's been
told in the political world for at least
10 years if not even longer is there's
these demographic shifts happening in
States like Florida and Texas and part
of it is age-related but a lot of it is
the growth of the Hispanic or Latino
population and it's just going to make
it difficult and eventually impossible
for Republicans to win Florida and Texas
and it hasn't played out and many people
are looking at the numbers and saying
okay is this happening is it what is it
going to play out what is happening with
that
well I think you have to take one thing
into account and this is maybe the most
important thing
Latinos the the common age of a Latino
David is 11. on say 11. that's the node
right scientifically speaking
mathematically speaking the common age
of a Latino is 11. lock that number in
because the common age of a uh a white
Anglo-Saxon non-latino in the United
States is 58.
so what that tells you is because
Latinos are young they're going to be
voting in the future more in line with
what we just saw some young people
voting in this last election so what
they're going to care about is not
like we hear today in parts of uh South
Florida but they're probably going to be
voting more in line with regular you
know American young people and that
would not bode well for the Republicans
but right now yeah Republicans have done
a great job in South Florida in
particular bringing into Venezuelan and
the Cuban vote and the others who come
from certain parts of Latin America by
telling them that if you vote Democrat
you're voting for Chavez you're voting
for Fidel Castro because all Democrats
are communists one of the things that
applies generally when it comes to
targeting young voters is that the right
seems much more committed financially to
setting up things like Turning Point USA
sending Ben Shapiro to college campuses
and paying handsome speaking
Etc you really don't see it as much on
on the left and it seems that the same
thing applies specifically to the
targeting of Latino voters where there's
lots of right-wing Spanish language
political content on the radio in the
United States but really not much
alternative to that
you know
one of the reasons I'm doing agua media
because it's really a bit of a passion
project for myself and for Solomon
Trujillo my partner
um you know Saul and I realized that if
we don't get the story out ourselves and
thank God we have a David Pacman who's
also a Latino who's also an influential
member of uh the media Community to be
able to tell the story that
unfortunately I wish MSNBC would tell
but they don't let's face it we're 20 of
the population in the United States and
we are underrepresented across the board
whether it's Hollywood or whether it's
on cable television Nancy Pelosi said
something interesting God love her and I
know she made a mistake and she's an
older woman and stuff and but she should
have known better soon after DeSantis
did this stunt where he literally
hijacked people or kidnap people and
sent them to another state from Texas
her response was what a shame because
imagine the farmers in Florida could
have used some of those immigrants for
example to pick their fruit and their
vegetables and I thought to myself Nancy
God bless you but that's not what you
say the answer is right now and in the
future sure Latinos will be the doctors
the business people they'll be the
people who create this unbelievably
enterprising uh economy of ours they
tend to hire more they tend to start
more small businesses you need to know
that Nancy when you talk about Latinos
and that's the problem and we don't get
it at CNN we don't get it at the msnbcs
and those are the ones who are supposed
to be our stalwarts and in that example
and it's not to beat up you know Nancy
Pelosi but yeah you know that's that's
the wrong mess that's the wrong counter
to the other argument that's important
David and that's why you and I guys like
you and I are out there to share these
things well one thing I want to ask you
about and I have no idea what your
position is on this so I could be
stepping into a Minefield here is one of
the things that when you talk about the
conversation among the left and Latino
Americans has to do with the gender
neutralizing of the Spanish language and
I'm talking about latinx and I'm taught
so that's in English Latin X and then
there's a movement in Spanish as well
well where it would take something like
the word Amigos or Amigas which are
gendered and create a new one which is
amiges with an e now my view is this is
a really bad idea I don't think this
makes any sense most people in Central
and South America don't use that later
example I gave Latin X is mostly being
proposed by white Americans I think that
this if this becomes the thing that is
the topic in the US among the left with
this population I think it's a disaster
where where are you on that we're just
throwing the right a bone to be able to
use to coalesce Latinos against
Democrats and then they could go with
that woke thing that you know is so
amorphous and opaque I don't even know
what the hell it means but don't do that
don't I mean I'm so proud of my mother
for everything she gave to me as you are
of your mother and your mother is a
Latina and my mother is a Latina and my
father is a a Latino I can't think of
describing Paco my dad as a latinx you
know what does that mean to me besides
if you're gonna do it with us Latinos
then you also have to do it with
Italians because they do use a
non-gender neutral uh you know language
because they all come from romance
languages and Romanians and the French
and every Portuguese and everything so
leave well enough alone as our as our
friend Willie Shakespeare said when it
comes to something like this and let's
tackle the really big issues that are
affecting Latinos in the United States
and not change their nomenclature it
just seems like a bridge too far it
almost seems like almost a little
insulting to me so when it comes to
latinx In fact when it comes to all
colorations I don't think we should be
brown I don't think we should be yellow
I don't think we should be black I think
you're an argentinian-american and I am
a Cuban American and my friend Jerry
over here who I'm looking at is a
Mexican-American and somebody can be a
jamaican-american or an irish-american
it's a better encryption in the old days
when you called someone a colored person
it was insulting and it seems like today
we want to bring that back and somehow
celebrate it I'm against Colors Let's
call each other as descriptively as we
can as we learned in journalism school
so that we understand how people are
described let's talk a little bit about
immigration and specifically DACA DACA
to me seems like it would be the lowest
hanging fruit that both Democrats and
Republicans would be incentivized to
figure out and deal with and say okay
here's something we've fixed so it's not
just endlessly a quote crisis now of
course the term crisis is exaggerated
and it's used uh you know right leading
up to an election and then suddenly you
don't hear about it for you we know all
of that stuff okay but on the DACA issue
it seems overwhelmingly popular to say
we're not going to send people back to
other countries who came here through no
fault of their own as minors with
parents why hasn't it happened is part
of it that neither side wants to allow
the other side to be able to take credit
for that I think to be honest with you
obviously Republicans have had a odd and
almost cruel view of that and have for
many many years with some exceptions so
you know we we can give some credit to
George Bush and we can give some credit
hell even the Lindsey Graham at some
point I don't know what the heck
happened to that guy there was a time
when he had a different way of thinking
about uh things like this yeah
um but unfortunately Democrats have
never really made this including you
know President Obama have never really
made this the priority that they that
they needed to make it to to to Really
make sure that they were uh uh you know
uh making strides with the Latino
Community where it matters you know
right here you know as we like to say
um and and that's you know I think to a
fault and and I think oftentimes
Democrats you know as I said in that
famous uh in that in that famous uh
documentary that Billy did uh you know
the thing about Democrats is they're
always trying to do the right thing and
please everybody and Republicans could
give a crap they just want to win so
Republicans don't care who they insult
and what they do as long as in the end
they can win uh that's kind of the
McConnell message right in many ways
which it's interesting now that they're
trying to kick him out and Democrats
instead have always kind of overplayed
things and be concerned about how it's
going to be seen and well if we come out
too heavy on this then we could lose
Middle America because we might lose
votes in the Midwest and they overthink
things so much and in the end they don't
do enough and I think if Democrats have
gotten on board DACA for example really
gotten on board
um I think they would be faring better
now and not fighting you know between 60
65 and 70 of the vote and and really
they would probably be topping out
around 80 because remember the people
that are affected by this especially are
the the people who are the larger part
of the Latino Community right the
Mexican-American and the Central
American part of the of those Latino
communities so it would make a huge
difference I think well hopefully we
will at least see some progress on that
at some point it may take Democrats
allowing Republicans to do it under
their watch to get that win and the
question is whether Democrats would go
for it because it's the right thing to
do even if they don't get all of the
political benefit
yeah yeah you know it's funny in this
last election I watched something happen
there was this guy who turned out to be
a pretty awful human being but for some
reason he and I used to talk a lot he
would call me at least once a week when
he was running Fox News and that's Roger
Ailes and he used to say to me and said
publicly in fact
that the funny thing about Republicans
is they don't tell you what they think
they just show up uh to uh the polling
place and uh show their actions with
their vote and they don't go around
giving their opinions
wow what a difference between what just
happened in this election not just with
Latinos but with others Republicans are
now the hippies of the 1970s they're the
ones having parades they're the ones
putting it out there I mean I would
never go screaming down the middle of
the street holding a banner of any
candidate we're putting bumper stickers
all over my house and doing all of those
things and that's what you see now with
with with Republicans and and you invite
them over to your backyard barbecue and
he happens to be your neighbor and he's
Republican and immediately starts
telling you who's going to vote for who
he hates and you're like okay here you
want a beer it's the weirdest it's the
weirdest thing that's interesting why
are you telling me this and uh that used
to be what Democrats were kind of like
in the 60s and 70s now Democrats just
keep their mouths shut they wait and
when it comes to vote they voted against
it and that's kind of what we saw in
this last midterm and it made me think
of the flip that maybe happened in our
society yeah and Roger rails captured
the quiet Republican and created a
television network for them right and
brought them out to the point now where
I guess they're loud and proud but not
effective right they're not quiet
anymore that's for sure no no that I
mean that's the point it's almost like
it's a counter-intuitive or ironically
different we've been speaking with Rick
Sanchez who's the co-founder CEO and
president of agua media Rick really a
pleasure having you on
it's a pleasure to be with you as well
David thanks so much and uh you know